[Music]
hello there you are watching the press
preview a first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive it's time to
see what's making the headlines with the
columnist at the daily mirror susie
boniface and the former conservative
special advisor anita boiteng they'll be
with us from now until just before
midnight so let's see what's on some of
those front pages for you now
the times reports that as few as six
patients in ten could be dealt with by
hospital a d departments within four
hours this winter calling it the winter
of woe
the telegraph also leads with a health
care story saying that a cyber attack
has disrupted the nhs 111 service
the financial times weekend edition
writes that tory leadership candidate
liz truss is opting for handouts over
tax cuts to help households with the
cost of living crisis
the express follows the sad turn in
events in the archie battersby case his
life support is due to be turned off at
10 am tomorrow morning
the mail says that transport secretary
grant shaps wants to impose tougher
prison sentences on cyclists who cause
the death of pedestrians
the mirror focuses on the hosepipe ban
facing millions of people in the uk
the guardian outlines the increasing
tensions between china and the u.s
saying that their relations have
deteriorated into further uncertainty
and the star describes a professor who
has successfully tricked people on
twitter
into believing that a new planet had
been discovered
when it was in fact a picture of a slice
of chorizo
looks exactly like a slice of chorizo to
me and a reminder that by scanning the
qr code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us
and uh we are joined tonight by susie
boniface and anita boateng thank you
ladies for joining us this evening um
let's start with the
telegraph and uh the telegraph have
declared for
liz trust they say six in ten readers uh
said the foreign secretary should
replace boris johnson uh this they're
describing as a fresh blow to rishi
sunax campaign susie
well it is a fresh blow if the daily
telegraph readership is indicative of
the tory membership and there's probably
a strong argument for saying that it is
but also that it isn't um
so you know it's they've managed to
question almost 10 000 of their own
readers to ask what they think
and they they've come out in favor of
lists but there's some really
interesting stuff buried deep down in
the survey as well as always the bit
right down in the back actually it's the
really juicy bits and considering the
fact that liz trust has been um a little
bit anti shall we say green levees and
things like that to help meet net zero
almost half of these daily telegraph
readers are backing net zero by 2050
and that could be a little bit awkward
it could be even more awkward if they
are truly indicative of the conservative
party membership because almost half of
them want net zero by 2050 but 39 which
is a very sizable minority
don't and if that is indicative of
conservative voters and conservative
party membership how is any leader going
to be able to balance a very narrow
majority in in their support and their
base for doing something very radical
and a very big minority in that same
base for not doing it at all let's get
that's going to be a massive headache
and further in there it also says that
two-thirds of them
don't want her to give a job to boris
johnson in her cabinet now
she's already said that she doesn't
think he would want that job she has
offered a job to rishi which it doesn't
seem like they've questioned her about
at least isn't reported on the front
page here
but um it's also that's kind of the
opposite of what the telegraph has been
saying elsewhere claiming that there are
thousands and thousands of tory members
who want boris johnson to stay in
government
so it's a bit of swings and roundabouts
uh it's a case of i think suck it and
see really it's one of those many
surveys you get in a leadership election
where you can go hmm well it might it
might not yeah and this um survey comes
amidst the the latest uh top tory to
back uh liz trust this is andrea
leadsome quoted as as saying um
mistrust would make sure every baby is
given the best start in life unite the
conservatives and lead a team drawn from
across the party and that surely has to
be another blow to to rishi soon act
doesn't it anita
yes well i think that honestly the
cabinet uh and and four members of the
cabinet see which way the wind is
blowing and very strategically are kind
of like
if i you know put my ore in everyone is
in politics to serve and want to serve
at the top table so i think there is an
element of that going on i think there's
other interesting details buried um in
that piece in the telegraph um that
we've just discussed which is really
about some of the things that liz trust
would do
were she to be elected um party leader
and prime minister one of them speaks of
the um emergency budget that she plans
to bring in which would
you know pause the green levy so these
are some of the additional um
things that put on to energy bills um
basically levied by the energy companies
that go towards investment in renewable
energy um she talks about reversing that
corporation tax hike which wasn't due to
coming immediately but nevertheless
would be quite a big thing for business
and also and this is the big one the
national insurance increase which was
introduced by the then chancellor rishi
sunak to pay for the nhs and social care
uplift in spending that she would
reverse that immediately and that is
some really interesting and quite bold
moves that shows that she's absolutely
not resigning from her tax cutting
agenda even as the tales from the bank
of england and the reports that we had
yesterday about you know astonishing
levels of inflation and also of
prolonged recession they're predicting
you know five quarters of recession um
for the next year and a half so things
are going to get very bumpy indeed and
the questions about how you balance
inflation with tax cuts will they be
inflationary in this instance all of
that is yet to play for but trust is
clearly if she wins going to go full
steam ahead with her proposals okay
before we we move on um anita is a
former conservative special adviser are
you at liberty to say who you are
backing
you know what i haven't got my obama
paper yet um and i haven't
i'm not sort of declaring i don't know
really why
um
i think i'm get i've got to the point
where i i've made my mind up but i
haven't publicly said so would you like
to would you like to
would you like to
keep everyone guessing
interesting susie right let's uh move on
staying with with the list trust though
in the front of the the ft um she's
insisting on on tax cuts it's saying
instead of of handouts to to help
households
yeah and one of the the phrases that she
uses in this interview is that she she's
criticizing the treasury is what she
calls abacus economics and abacus
anyone who doesn't remember primary
school it's the little thing with people
that you use to sort of click sums up
and down it was it's sort of partly how
civilization began counting thousands of
years ago and it's still of some use now
i'm just saying it's still sold actually
that just makes me think i don't think
i've seen an advocacy for years
who knows we might need one if we all
end
up you know live on the black market as
it were but you know she's saying
i don't want to um
it's just the treasury in their abacus
economics it's like saying oh well
they're just using maths you can prove
anything with maths you know
of course they're using an abacus is
counting and subtraction it's it's
pretty basic math that's a good thing i
thought um but what we're talking about
here fundamentally she's talking about
making big tax cuts as anita suggested
um whether or not that would have an
inflationary impact now all the
independent
economic experts most of them should say
not all but most of those that i've uh
that have been in in the media and
certainly interviews who aren't
affiliated to one side or the other are
saying look if you make tax cuts that is
going to embed inflation in in the
higher prices will just be there forever
if you do give what she would call a
handout which is
one way of describing giving taxpayers
money back to the taxpayers it's our
cash remember it's not a handout it's
just it's the same as a tax cut really
they're all handouts aren't they um if
you give a handout as it were to deal
with something like the cost of fuel and
energy then that would actually cost
fewer billions and have less of an
inflationary impact although there would
still be one perhaps in the short term
um so trust his plans apparently they
say it doesn't even cover the rise in
energy bills that we now look like we're
facing which are going to rise every
three months rather than every six
months
um and she plainly hasn't had her energy
bill through yet and hasn't quite
perhaps done the sums on her own abacus
at home and of course if the bank of
england is right in what as anita was
saying that what they were saying about
uh predicting a recession
then liz doesn't have the fiscal
headroom which she claims to have i
either the space the savings if you like
in the in the in the bank account to
actually make any of these cuts so
although um anita is saying well she's
plenty going to follow through with all
this yes she's very very definite about
it but i do think when she gets into
government and the same would go for
issue to some extent the things they
have said to their membership in order
to get elected are things that are not
necessarily going to be workable
on days one to 574 however
it was ever thus uh we must leave it
there for the moment and take a break uh
anita and susie when we continue with
the press preview this story we'll be
looking at in the mail their headline
reckless cyclists face jail crackdown
do stay with us for much more
[Music]
[Music]
ben stokes new englander rewriting test
cricket express yourself it's a record
chase for england in test cricket
as
but can south africa outrun them that is
monumental or will england hit even
greater heights
england v this
africa the first test wednesday the 17th
of august to add sky sports go to
sky.com sports
i have decided to name a new heir
i'm your hair
dragons a power man should never have
trifled with
war
is a foot
knives will come out
now they see you
as you are
here comes a question what's special
about the hp pavilion it's got windows
11 says rita and the touch screen lets
you tap zoom snap and swipe so that'd be
good for teaching my art class i'll find
out she says
paris because like all curry's experts
rita here leaves no question unanswered
so she knows when she says yes it's very
good the touchscreen makes everything
easier and she knows it's interest-free
from just 17.87 a month for 24 months at
curry's
[Music]
tesco finest ultimate brisket and chuck
burgers made with succulent cuts of
prime aberdeen angus beef now just 2
pounds 50 with your tesco club cardo app
anna stayed at this hotel and paid this
price
laura stayed at the same hotel and paid
a lot less how
well anna found the hotel on her usual
website laura on the other hand used
travago to compare offers from major
booking sites and found a great deal
hotel trivago
flames setting fire to your skin it's
burning it could be a symptom of thrush
treat the symptoms and the cause and get
complete belief with canister and thrush
combi say it as it is to treat it as it
is
right now at wren you can get 50 off
kitchen units and up to five years
interest-free credit
plus you can lock in the price of your
new kitchen for 18 months with a fully
refundable 10 deposit the rent inflation
stopping sale now on
[Music]
[Music]
ready set summer with tattoo holidays
now's the time to get away so come on
discover amazing sunny destinations
with four and five star hotels and 22
kilograms of baggage included
don't miss out
book now
jet two holidays package holidays you
can trust astronaut protected
fast delivery
unmissable tv
all included with prime
welcome back you're watching the press
previews still with me the columnist at
the daily mirror susie boniface and the
former conservative special adviser
anita batten welcome back to both of you
let's have a look at the mail front page
uh and this is a story regarding um
reckless cyclists and grant schatz is
wanting to make changes
to the law anita
yes i mean actually this story this
issue of death by dangerous cycling has
been around for quite a long time at
least four years certainly when i was in
government um this was a topic of
conversation but basically um grant
chaps is now confirming that government
is going to go ahead with measures and
effectively change a slightly archaic
rule that means it's quite hard um
basically if you cause a death by
dangerous cycling which happens very
rarely but does happen you end up
getting up to 18 months in jail and
obviously the sentence for um death by
dangerous driving is up to 10 years i
believe so it's about addressing that
discrepancy um which i think you know
could be a welcome step in making sure
that in those rare instances there is a
way to make sure that people um you know
are held accountable for dangerous
cycling but i think the broader thing
that the dft is doing around making
roads safer for pedestrians and cyclists
and cars are the things that are going
to deliver the material improvements
that we all want to see
susie do you think that that's fair that
reckless cyclists are treated exactly
the same as as dangerous drivers
well the number of deaths are only one
percent of what's caused on the roads by
cars but it's absolutely right that they
should you know and the victims of those
kind of crimes should have the justice
and everything else that they're
entitled to but i feel about a thousand
years old am i the only person here who
ever did a cycling proficiency test
because when i came through primary
school all the kids if you wanted to
ride your bike to school you had to do
the course you had to do the highway
code yes and that was where you learned
you know how to turn left and turn right
and everything else i think anita's done
it because she's nodding
how many cyclists today
have you ever seen with a bell on their
bike and who actually use it to warn
people that they're there
it's kind of you know what the highway
code and how to behave on the roads as a
cyclist is something that you should
have to learn or be taught not just
something that you have to pick up as
you go along because there are children
who go out
riding their bikes with their parents at
the weekend some of whose parents teach
them well some of whom go out by
themselves and you're just learning sort
of by guess work we wouldn't let people
drive a car or a lorry or a tank
with guesswork and trying to work it out
for themselves you give them a bit of
training to start with and just makes
perfect sense to me as both a cyclist
and a motorist that we just make sure
that everyone who goes out on the roads
driving a piece of metal at some speed
and capable of causing death or injury
just has the basic training cycling why
isn't the transport secretary talking
about the cycling proficiency test i
hope he's listening
you've got that off at your chest but
also the the rules have changed haven't
they because cyclists um the rules in
terms of how far they cycle from the
curb that's that's changed and drivers
also need to know for their own safety
uh what the cycling rules are let's have
a look at the
mirror um anita take us here into this
i'll just uh read the headline dust bowl
uk and the picture speaks for itself
doesn't it
it absolutely does um well not only is
the sculpture continuing we believe it's
going to get worse and hos hosepipe
bands are coming in or coming on the
south and southeast part of the country
so there's going to be a lot of um you
know curtain twitching from neighbours
um checking to see suspiciously green
lawns um throughout the summer um and
the advice from thames water i got an
email earlier saying well basically let
your lawn go dry you know this is what
you've got to do to preserve water
and i think that it's going to be one of
many challenges that we're going to see
um this year the only thing we can hope
is that everyone acts responsibly
because we really have to make sure that
we are conserving where we can
a little bit uncomfortable this sort of
ratting on your neighbor though isn't it
susie i wouldn't do it well yes i think
there's probably some there are probably
some better solutions i mean first off
the picture on the front of the mirror
there about the source of the thames
being dry i've walked the length of the
thames and been at the source and it's
dry every summer right at the top there
but it's the case of how far down from
the source that it remains dry is it a
mile half mile six miles from the source
that it's still dry who knows but in
case in terms of actually being
personally responsible why isn't every
homeowner being advised to have a water
bar or perhaps help to do so why isn't
um everyone every new house being built
with water but underground water bugs
and grey water saving devices and
rooftop storage tanks why are water
companies being allowed to drill into
aquifers and empty the underground water
sources so we don't have sources of
supply during dry periods
why
why when we have so many billions of
pounds and private companies running our
system do we not have a pipeline from
areas of the country that have lots of
rain to areas of the country with less
risk
lots of wise i have none of the answers
but very good uh questions susie and
anita
thank you very much for taking us
through the papers see you later